streaming services are great for people
who listen to lots of music they offer
everything from the laces hits to
evergreens there are millions of songs
to choose from to help users find the
ones they like services provide
recommendations like a personalized mix
of the week most of these playlists are
generated automatically using algorithms
Stefan Bauman from the German Research
Center for artificial intelligence knows
how recommendation systems work he's
been researching the topic for over 15
years there are different approaches to
generating automated recommendations one
is content analysis which breaks a piece
of music down into its individual
components does the steam fazil asif in
the system tries to find out what is on
each individual track on the base here
you can see where notes are played and
where they're not the nodeb individual
employees lofty on the structures are
automatically analyzed in this way the
content based approach can use this
information to find similar songs with a
similar baseline battlefield another
approach collaborative recommendations
your taste in music is compared with
that of other users algorithms are
suited to generating these kinds of
recommendations but the results aren't
always convincing Baumann says the human
touch is still required Duncan via of
counties are huge for Noah coup de
musique we can use algorithms and
machines to make a preliminary selection
from the flood of good new music coming
out around the world here but in the end
it's still missing human expertise and
savviness about current trends zeitgeist
eating this knowledge is something only
people have Jesus vision is involved by
mention say a present like Julian altar
she's a playlist curator who puts
together digital mixtapes ash Dixter
she thinks users benefit from having a
human curate their playlist
and I'm song what a brand new song has
just been released we can react right
away and add it to our playlist okay
again and ones are playing this and see
you whatever me that's good for laughs
or if we feel that a newcomer is really
great but still a complete unknown to
our machine we can just give him or her
a prominent place on our playlist
playlist lezian of that was able sis
files video streaming services are also
growing in popularity one in every five
Germans uses them to watch TV series and
films here to collaborative
recommendations aimed too much users
tastes
but the video platform still rely on
human input to some streaming services
regularly put pilot episodes for a
variety of series on the internet only
the ones with high user ratings actually
go into production Julian Alta also
receives many tips from the online
community she trusts real users more
than computer algorithms yeah I
Whipple's MA yeah the algorithm also
recommends music yesterday you listen to
this song so you might like this one but
it doesn't always hit the bullseye maybe
I just played that Thun yesterday on a
whim if the problem that streaming
services are already working on they're
also hoping to tailor recommendations to
the users current situation as a cello
music bank shot sure listen to music
while I'm jogging listen to music while
I'm partying in my living room and while
I'm driving I'm constantly switching
between different duties and areas in my
life I impose a bed and a big trend in
recommendation systems right now is that
they're adding a new dimension voyage
time beat that soon in and he also the
hope is that we'll be able to deliver
better recommendations because we can
optimize them for the listeners
consciousness optum younkin but to do
that streaming services require even
more data which means users must divulge
more information about themselves so
maybe more conventional playlists are
the better alternative
you